I think very much and knowing Chris has
both Bob and I know him pretty well he's
he likes solitude but it was very
obvious that he is ready for some some
some human interaction with with us as
far as in the u.s. segment obviously
Scott his two Russian crewmates but I
think he's looking very much forward to
us coming up there and at least trying
to help him out some arrival goes I
think Dunn and I were both extremely
excited to return to the Kennedy Space
Center and get a chance to fly around
the facility a little bit we didn't land
immediately there was always a they're
always timing issues that people are
trying to have as a consideration as you
come in for an event like that so we did
get a chance to make a little bit of a
tour of the the local area rather than
doing a full full stop straight in which
allowed us to reminisce about all the
times that Doug and I have flown in here
both escaped Crusaders but as astronauts
over the years and certainly dozens of
times together coming to work at the
Kennedy Space Center it just was an
exciting thing to go through one more
time leading up to launch was exciting
to see next we'll take Marcia Dunn from
The Associated Press
tene and if so will that continue right
up until lunch day and I'm also
wondering if you've ever been so
medically scrutinized in your entire
lives your question got cut off
it sounded like you were somewhere in
the middle of saying the word
quarantined and as far as so I asked
that as soon as I answer the second part
there
this medical scrutiny I think for us has
other than maybe the Cova testing it has
been like it normally is it's we've
always we've been scrutinized for 20
years 20-plus years since we interviewed
for this job so and it seems like every
year the scrutiny gets greater so from
that perspective I think it's it's been
relatively normal comparatively speaking
and and we just I think after all these
years we're just kind of used to the
poking and prodding and blood draws and
all the other things that come along
with flying into space so what was the
other part of your question Marcia
yes I'm wondering if you're still being
tested for Co vat19 and if that will
continue right up until liftoff
well I think from a medical standpoint I
don't think anybody recommends we get
tested every day we've been tested at
least twice so far and rumor has it we
might be tested again before we go so I
think in general that seems like plenty
especially considering we've been in
this and for all intents and purposes a
quarantine now since about March 15th is
is my recollection so I think that's I
think we're doing pretty good so from
that standpoint we have been in
quarantine probably longer than any
other space space crew has ever been in
the history of the space program just
been really familiar with the quarantine
process over the years as you know
active astronauts we've seen it for
ourselves and all of our compadres who
are inside the office but that we've
seen the rest of the world have to take
on the same sort of precautions that we
do leading up to launch and that's been
a good thing in some sense for for Doug
and I it has allowed the opportunity for
us to spend some time with our our young
children who would have been below the
age of access if you will for a
quarantine if if they weren't home from
school and so that's been a little bit
of a tiny bit of sliver of silver lining
that we've had as the time with our son
is leading up at this launch which would
have they would have not normally been
inside of our quarantine next we'll hear
from Jackie Goddard with Times of London
princess badass I suspect if I ask each
of you to elaborate on what makes you a
badass you're you'll be you're modest
and say you're not and that you're just
doing a job so I'd like to ask Bob
what makes Doug about us and Doug what
makes Bob one thanks and have a safe
ride I'll let you rephrase no it's it's
a it's a great question and a good way
to get us through the gap there but Doug
is ready for anything
all the time he's always prepared and
know when you're gonna fly into space on
a test mission that's you couldn't ask
for a better person or a better type of
individual to be there with you and so
I'm just thankful that doing something
like this I'm doing it with with Doug
Hurley because he's he's gonna be
prepared for whatever comes our way and
he's going to be prepared quickly so I
couldn't ask for more as far as Bob you
know he is the quiet
bad and then I'll let you put in the
next word but he just doesn't there is
no stone unturned
there is no no way that he he doesn't
have every potential eventualities
already thought about you know five
times ahead of almost anybody else and
so there's just there's there's no
question I can ask him that he doesn't
already have probably the best answer
for and and it's just been you know it's
just such a just a pleasure and it's
it's such a you know an asset to have
somebody like that on a crew with you
that just he's already got it all
figured out everything that we could
possibly you know potentially deal with
and and it just it just makes it so much
easier when you have somebody like that
with your crew we're gonna take both of
us I think as we head to Space Station
because I think
of course one of the cassidy or the Navy
SEALs models is uh you know have a plan
for every situation and dispatch of it
appropriately and so between the two of
us maybe we can keep up with Chris Cass
thank you okay we're going to take a
question from Twitter now and we have
Robert on Twitter who asked many of the
America's previous spacecraft with crews
had named where three-three was freedom
seven and Gemini three was called Molly
Brown do you have you guys named your
crew dragon we do have a name and we
will break it out appropriately and and
we'll we've got something for you to
look forward to on launch day yeah this
this goes along with kind of some of the
traditions and we've talked about this
many times and and you know not only Bob
and I but several other folks within our
office and the crew one and and now the
crew two folks and certainly the folks
on the Boeing side all think it's a
great idea and a tradition we should
continue so we feel honored to continue
this tradition we will look forward to
that for sure and next on Twitter from
oh and plum who is 13 he wants to know
are you bringing any payloads with you
any payloads aspect of it we do have
some small items that are break they're
coming up to the International Space
Station but our primary responsibility
is to get ourselves up there and so the
amount of payload activity that we have
on board is pretty minimal once we
arrive at Space Station I know that will
be supporting operations associated with
the HTV that should be arriving soon
after we do both for potentially
spacewalks as well as other experimental
hardware that's inside of that vehicle
so we're primarily crew transport and
we've got some extra hardware that we'll
leave behind on space station to
facilitate future dragons arriving on
the International Space Station but our
payload
number our payload mass is pretty
limited okay we'll go back to the phone
now this next question will be from
Chris Davenport with the Washington Post
Chris whoo yeah we met him before Chris
are you on okay we need to go I guess
too next to a Miriam Kramer with Axios
hi there I thank you guys for doing this
so with this being a time of such great
uncertainty for folks around the u.s. I
just wonder what you hope this launch
will mean to people as they watch it
from their home thanks I think the thing
that we most want to bring home is that
we're still able to do this and perform
it safely
you know Kovac did Drive some changes
and how we were conducting our
operations and preparing for this
mission but we as a nation all across
the nation
you know folks from Florida through
Texas both in Houston and at McGregor
with the SpaceX team as well as in
California had to figure out a way to
still pull this mission off safely still
prepare for it safely still work
together to accomplish it even with all
the constraints that you know really
prevented the togetherness that we had
been exercising the previous five years
you know we had spent a lot of time out
in the Hawthorn face to face with the
team and I know the the Houston
travelers had to figure out a way to not
necessarily do that as often and so I
hope the the nation can look at this and
recognize that this is something we're
still going to accomplish this is still
something that we're going to still be
successful at and we're gonna do it in
the base of a you know the pandemic
we'll figure out a way to to work
through it and work around it and work
through it safely so we mentioned
already that will continue to be coded
tested as we lead up to launch because
of course don't want to take that to the
International Space Station but you know
where there's a will there's a way and
there's been will to make this happen
and we're just proud to be a part of it
next up we'll go to Lucas from SpaceX
hi MA so my question is what are your
flight suits like compared to other
suits you are seen of on that military
test pilot or an astronaut training
spacesuits that we wear on crew dragon
are similar in what they're designed to
do as other pressure suits in case
there's a whole breach or a loss of
pressurization within the vehicle
these suits would pressurize and keep us
safe they're very unique relative to the
suits that we we've tried before are
worn before shuttle we wore the Asus
suit which was the larger orange suit it
was quite a bit more bulky and it was
kind of sized generically rather than
these particular suits for SpaceX
they're they're custom sized to the
individual and obviously I think a lot
of people think they are really
neat-looking suits and they do the job
one thing I would say is SpaceX designed
and built and developed these suits from
the ground up which is unique usually
there's a separate company or companies
involved that make these space suits and
so it was really neat to be there from
the very beginning of the development of
these suits to the to the two suits that
we just tried on this morning to just
check them one more time before we get
ready to go fly now we'll go to Rachel
joy from Florida today is a bit of a
delay so hopefully you can hear me I'm
40 today is the local paper here on the
Space Coast and I can tell you that our
readers are just so excited and proud
that you're here and and would love to
know a little bit more about what your
plans are this weekend for Memorial Day
I know it's a little weird you're in
quarantine and maybe if you could reveal
some of your local favorite spots around
town I know if there's restaurants or
beaches you go to when you are able to
get out well I'll take at least part of
that question
we lost the screen you guys still there
yeah I'm here okay yeah it's our screen
locked up there for a second okay the
video is still locked up but it sounds
like you can hear us yeah so for the
weekend we I think we're good now
Brandon for the weekend where were
following the schedule we're still in
quarantine so yeah it'll be a unique
Memorial Day weekend for us being a
quarantine the good thing is is our
families arrive tomorrow so we'll get to
see them but there's just continuing
schedule if for example tomorrow is the
dry dress so that'll be a kind of the
dress rehearsal for launch day and then
Sunday and Monday we have plenty of
scheduled events as we work our way
towards launch on Wednesday so the long
and the short of it is is it's a little
bit of what we like to call Groundhog
Day which is quarantine but there's
plenty of things to do and hopefully
we'll get a chance to be outside maybe
get out to the beach house and at least
enjoy kind of some of the traditional
things that folks will enjoy or hope to
enjoy on most Memorial days and as far
as I think your other question was the
where do we like to go when we can get
out pretty much anywhere anywhere in
Cocoa Beach it's always just neat to get
out see the beach and some of the
different restaurants and places that we
we try to go whenever we get down here
but the docks will not allow it on this
trip yeah no I get this so we won't be
seeing you at the sandbar that's fun no
probably not unfortunately but we we
certainly like to say hi to everybody
there if there is anybody there that's
the other thing I don't even know if
it's are they are those places open to
some degree in a limited fashion or or
not at all all right next up we'll go to
Steven Clark with Space Flight now I
thank you for taking my question first
of all I don't have a manual flying
demonstration during your train
to the space station you talk about
which of you is actually going to be
flying the vehicle in your roles during
during the flight up to ISS your for
each of you and also your votes elected
as astronauts in 2000 sort of in the
heart of the shuttle program did you
ever expect to be flying anything in
space besides the shuttle when you
joined the astronaut office
thanks for the manual flying I'll be
doing the manual flying as the dragon
commander and we will do a manual flying
demo in free flight and then we'll do
another one when we get closer to the
ISS and you know it's a it's certainly
though those tests are kind of
two-person tests for sure because
there's a lot of back-and-forth between
Bob and I and and you know we practice
that quite a bit and it's obviously
something that we want to make sure we
understand completely for future crews
in case they ever have to fly the
vehicle manually as far as the second
question you know I think both of us
would really have been just over the
moon if we had the opportunity when we
first arrived to fly on a new spacecraft
and over the years you know we've seen
NASA complete the space station and then
consider what the next steps were going
to be and so we've longed to be a part
of a test mission a test space flight
and Doug and I are lucky enough to get
that opportunity going forward so I
would say it's something we maybe
dreamed about when we were new Askins
calling something other than the space
shuttle the next vehicle it did not seem
likely at the time when when we arrived
in the astronaut office there was a lot
of assembly of the International Space
Station that had to happen and so we
needed to get through that and we were
just excited to have our opportunities
on those missions and that happened many
years ago so I think we're where we're
living the dream this what I guess
astronaut Michael Michael Fossum would
have said if he was that posed with that
question okay next we're gonna go to
Dave Moser with Business Insider I thank
you guys for doing this and best of luck
on your flight so you both said this is
an experimental flight and basically an
astronauts dream to do a test flight
but is there still a good amount of risk
in it and I'm curious if if and how
mission management has shared LLC or LOM
numbers with you in you know what you
think about those numbers how how
confident you are moving forward with
what the template thank you I think
whenever we we hear those numbers we dig
a little bit deeper than just what the
overall you know statistics might might
imply and those numbers are best used as
you kind of compare different ways of
doing things or hardware changes that
you might pursue or otherwise we've had
full information I think from the
Commercial Crew program from the SpaceX
team as we've gone forward with this and
so I think we've had the luxury over the
last five plus years to be deeply
embedded and understanding of the traits
that were made and and as you as you
probably understand there's there often
cases where a hardware change can be
implemented or there can be an
operational change that reduces that
risk or manages it in some way and so
we've been deeply involved in that
entire process and so we didn't even get
a chance over the last two days to duck
our heads into the agency's Flight
Readiness review and hear the
discussions that the management teams
were having about the overall risk or
different ways of doing business with
this mission itself and so I think we're
really comfortable with it and and you
know we we think that those trades have
been made appropriately and as far as
insight goes we've had probably more
than any crew has in recent history just
in terms of understanding the different
scenarios that are on our plate those
numbers are are certainly part of the
equation when you assess risk but
they're certainly not exclusive by any
stretch of the imagination they change
based on a lot of different design
changes or just statistics as we move
forward in a program so they're
certainly a factor but there's just so
much more to assessing risk and and all
those things that you need to you know
put into the decision matrix before you
go fly but anyway I think really
unique things about the the dragon
vehicle is the legacy that they have
with cargo so they have the team has
that experience as well as the Falcon 9
rocket that has what wasn't a long
history when we started this program but
as kind of playing and out and to be
quite a number of flights under its belt
and its evolution has become more and
more safe as it's been operated and
that's something that we really do
appreciate and it's just remarkable to
see all the other missions that have
contributed to the human spaceflight
program by you know in some sense being
a test mission for us before we had the
chance to fly on the Falcon 9 thank you
okay I think that is all the time we
have for questions unfortunately I
apologize says that we didn't get to but
since this is our last time to talk with
Bob and I before we see them next week
we want to wish them luck let them they
will be cheering them on and for those
on the phone you will need to hang up
and dial into the next briefing that's
coming up here on NASA TV at 2:45 and
will be the post-fight readiness review
briefing again we'll see you all back
here on launch day May 27th thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]